we arrived for our 6 50 flight they said
there's gonna be some delays at first it
wasn't until about
8 30 in the morning that we found out
about the cancellation
before they announced it to uh the
terminal we actually
checked the app so we found out through
the app before anyone from spirit
actually told us
about the cancellation waited until
there was personnel at the counter
because there was no one at the counter
i had to wait for personnel for them to
tell me i had to leave to come to
ticketing
just to be able to fix my flight
i've never in my life through any other
airline carrier if i had to leave to go
to ticketing to fix my flight never
beyond frustrated angry upset
disappointed i mean i'm i'm going to
detroit for
a job interview just rumors kind of
circulating throughout the lawn
um that spirit won't be available until
wednesday or
maybe even thursday so we probably will
have to switch airlines would be my
guess
if we're trying to get out of here i
feel like they're not handling the
situation very well
they seem pretty disingenuous and
honestly pretty unapologetic about the
whole situation
kind of have a reputation for being not
being the best
airline in general and i think that's
kind of holding true today